john stockwell was a high cia official
for 12 years
he quit at that time
and wrote the book in search of enemies
there was also a documentary made about
john and his experiences in the cia and
his life
this documentary has been seen over a
lot of the world in film festivals
sweden
united states
and in germany
but never on any of the tv networks
including public television
john uranono
well we'll find out why and john will be
able to speak free and uninhibitedly
tonight as everybody always does on
alternative views news magazine
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening welcome to alternative
views tonight we have a very special
program for you featuring john stockwell
john was a former cia officer who wrote
a book exposing the cia operations in
angola called in search of enemies
last year we had john on for a two-hour
special portrait discussion in which we
discussed how he got into the cia what
disillusioned him about cia operations
and had one of the first television
discussions of the activities of the c i
a their recruitment their day by day
operation and the problems that they
that the cia causes for american foreign
policy and the subversion of american
values that are their daily practice
tonight we're going to have a follow-up
to this we will begin with a documentary
film on the life of john stockwell it
was made by sal landau and haskell
wexler this excellent documentary was
shown in many foreign film festivals
that won a lot of prizes but needless to
say it has never been shown on american
television so we'll have the
tv debut tonight of the documentary by
john stockwell
about john stockwell we will also have a
special news feature in which we will
show you how the network television news
covered the story about the russian
troops that were supposedly discovered
in cuba and the manufactured crisis and
the political uproar that this caused we
will have john's reaction to the network
covering of this story and we'll have a
account that goes behind the scenes that
tells you how this story was actually
manufactured we will also have a special
one-hour discussion with john that will
discuss his current views on the cia
particularly why he thinks the cia
should be abolished and why it is a
counterproductive agency that is really
subversive of our democracy and the
primary american values that we believe
in we'll begin john with having a
discussion with you about the
documentary that was made could you tell
us a little bit about how this film was
made and what your reaction to it is
before we actually look at it
yes i think it's an
interesting story the way
seoul landau and haskell wexler put it
together they came
down to to austin to do the filming part
of it done on up on lake travis and part
of it around town here
i think it covers
uh
various aspects of
of sort of how john stockwell got to be
with my my childhood in africa and
marine corps experience and whatnot
it its statements about the cia are
pretty good
i did have one reservation about it when
it was all over though that i think is i
appreciate having the opportunity to to
say before you see the film
and that's that
saul landau
checked me out so to speak look me over
and decided that
as as he put it he's a political
activist that i would be more effective
as he put it if i were presented as an
ex-marine officer who would have been
happy with the cia if it had been
efficient
and that's that's not why i gave up my
career and and uh quit the cia and and
committed the career suicide economic
suicide that i did i think it's
certainly an argument against the cia
that it's incredibly
inefficient and ineffective but that
comes after
several other issues like the morality
of an organization that has committed
acts of terrorism around the world
killing hundreds of thousands of people
and discrediting the united states and
making the world a much less safe place
for
for us to live and do business in john
what about distribution and showing of
the film it's been shown overseas it's
been shown in film festivals but the
networks including pbs won't touch it
what's the background on that well
that's pretty much says it right there
it was shown at the new york film
festival and provoked
the biggest discussion of any film that
was shown there it was shown at a german
film festival and and likewise
was uh not controversial it provoked a
great discussion about the cia
on swedish national television german
national television
throughout europe and various parts of
the third world
the u.s networks of course the big east
won't show any film they haven't done
themselves
and so they wouldn't consider it and pbs
looked at it various pbs stations looked
at it and none of them were willing to
show it for their own reasons
i don't think it's that controversial it
i've gone much further in my lecturing
and the comments that we make
on this panel it i do not in that film
call for a closure of the cia
which which in fact i do believe
as a patriotic american that the cia
should be closed down
well we're going to see the movie now
right yeah let's see the movie first
okay so this you should
yeah i was proud
i mean
my dad works for the cia you know
i don't uh pretend to think that we
would have had a very successful
marriage even if we had not been in the
cia he could go along with it so far and
then
personal benefits were out
it was strictly a matter of principle
i learned he was a cia officer this last
year
oh good spy good i got i got to find out
something he did you know
i've been straight
all my life in terms of
working my way through college and and
the gates rubber company was a
conservative company a good one and
very conservative straight
the marine corps
and then 12 years in the cia
a team man an organization man
i think with my own
individuality
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i went up to the sawmill for one final
load of lumber of course he was alone
and a friend of his congolese family
was with us bob was driving
this boy was riding on the top of the
truck
top of the lumber
and in crossing a plane we saw an
equivalent of a wild turkey so he raised
his 22 and shot from
the cab
and dropped the bird in its tracks
and then he called his friend up on top
of the load of lumber the first one to
it gets it
and that was quite a race because it
meant a lot to both of them bob won by
maybe a yard
and
so we shared the bird with the other
missionaries
things like that
in their experience and background that
they couldn't get over here and then his
mother could tell you some stories about
some of his adventures first time he
wanted to go
on a an antelope hunt well it was a
place where they drove quite a ways in
the car and then had to walk and uh
never had any missionary children gone
and i said why bob of course you can't
go
he says now mother you told me that i'd
live until god was ready for me
to end this life and i want to go
and we let him go he killed an antelope
and in the night here came this great
commotion in the yard
and
he had sent some africans in with this
antelope he was 15 years old
so you went from a clean upbringing into
a world of dirty tricks in your mature
life
yeah
but the key thing is that as you get
recruited into the cia it never occurs
to you that if you're if you're as naive
as i was uh and i think most of the
young men that come into the ciar it
never occurs to you that you're getting
into a world of dirty tricks
you the the come on that they have the
the things they use to sell is that
you're finally getting into the elite
inner circles of the united states
government
all your life you've been going through
the amateurs and the prelims and the
the prep schools in effect and finally
this is it this is where the people are
real pros
the front line warriors saving the
nation from communists
the phoenix program was created by the
cia and its purpose was to kill and
terrorize and vietnam was forced to do
business with a police chief who was a
sadistic
mutilator of prisoners he liked to carve
them up and throw the remains in the
river
and he was completely paid and propped
up by the ci his whole career depended
on one controlling that operation so the
cia needed him and two uh the cia
propping him up and funding him
and he did his uh
knife work in a ci safe house we call it
the pink house i reported this to the
chief of station he said well you know
it's a rough world and sometimes you
have to do business with people that
really aren't your first choice of
the kind of people you want to associate
with so don't make a way
and so i went back you know what do i do
resign my post yeah you know that's
obviously that's your last vote though
you resign and you're out
and i wasn't ready to give up my career
yet i terminated the safe house
i told the case officers that i don't
want to hear about it if this guy has a
compulsion to do this sort of thing
anymore
i don't want to hear about it how does
the cia go about recruiting its future
candidates for officers and asians
hmm have any of you all been approached
here as recruiters come through here and
talk to me
[Music]
you know somebody in this room might be
sweating right now because he's been
told you know if they ask you don't say
anything
i hear that they do use professors to
keep eyes out in their classes for um
particular students who might
be interested in that sort of work but i
wonder how were you approached here at
the university or we approached sometime
later in your career at the university a
ci recruiter came through i went and
talked to them he did not write my name
down and in 64 early 64 i got a letter
in the mail saying would i mind if the
cia did a security check
and i wrote back saying i was restless
and i wrote back saying i'd be delighted
if it was uh
for possible employment with my
background there were fields where i
would be unique
from the congo i went to the university
of texas and enrolled in the rotc
program
i graduated in 1959 and took a
commission in the marine corps
i didn't see my future as a career
officer so when my term was up i
accepted an offer as a junior executive
at the gates rubber company and went
with my family to colorado
we were very young and idealistic with
three children when the cia first
approached us
we were in the marine corps for three
years and did not want to go the
military route although there was a very
promising career there when you think
about
his job being a career or national
security i think that at the time the
emphasis was career i think that
most of what he did was for the next
fitness report so to speak
i think that
people
generate
activity that is unnecessary overseas
in order to have some activity on their
fitness report and they really don't get
promoted within the cia
unless they have so many recruitments
let's say in a tour of duty are
so many operations or ops as they call
them the way the cia works you're
promoted on the basis of your fitness
report which you get every few months or
at the end of every assignment
at least once a year usually more often
and this evaluates your performance both
with a letter grade and also a written
narrative
that and the assignments you get will
will develop your career i said why
don't you just go in there and tell them
that this is immoral and this is
something you can't do
and he said well they don't want you're
not going to get anywhere in your career
if you say no to assignments
and by that time though he was
hooked by the cia and
the assignments were sexy assignments
and interesting assignments
in one post we put
seven bugs in a foreign embassy it was a
quite dramatic and very exciting and we
had
officers and support officers and
technicians flying all over africa on
this thing and we got them in of the
seven bugs that we installed clean we
never got caught
five of them never came up on the air
they were totally defective
the sixth one
uh would transmit but you the the switch
the activator to shut off the thing when
no one was speaking
uh was defective so it burned out its
batteries in the course of about six
weeks time and went off the air and one
of them functioned properly and that one
although it was in an ambassador's
office of a country that was very much a
target of intelligence uh activities
that one never produced a single
disseminable report
i felt like i was really making time uh
professionally i was a very young
officer when i met my first president we
had a mutual interest there were things
i could do for him and
there were things he could do for us at
least in terms of making me feel secure
in his country
if i was meeting him and he appreciated
what i was doing for him it wasn't
likely that he was going to throw me out
if i made a mistake or got caught
and it was pretty heady stuff for a very
young officer and uh it meant that i was
getting recognition back at headquarters
obviously you know there's young
stockwell who's meeting president x
and
we better keep our own stock well he
looks good my function at home when
agents would come to the home would be
to turn on the
uh record player and be sure that the
curtains were closed and that there was
enough security in my own home that the
person wouldn't
you know be compromised by having come
to our home
i didn't really at that time i didn't
realize
that we would be putting these people in
danger and that some would be put in
jail and that some would be dead
a lot of other things happen in the
world that's sort of like
somebody pushing a rock off the cliff
and the rock hit somebody and uh
and then you know they step back and say
i didn't kill them the the rock killed
him and this is sort of what happened in
ghana
the
the agency to my knowledge did not write
a paper saying let's overthrown kruman
the chief of station there was a very
aggressive man and he became aware of
the fact that there was the possibility
of a coup
developing and he knew the players
people who in the army who were unhappy
and he began to report and to to ask for
encouragement to encourage these men and
as i understand it he was not given
a formal permission to attempt
overthrowing kruma
but he was given permission to monitor
the developments of any coup
and this gave him an excuse to to meet
these officers
often daily several times a day and to
give them
money
and in effect to give them encouragement
the soft file is a file that doesn't
have an official name on it or
kryptonium on it and is not registered
into the agency's ibm system the system
of 201 numbers
so that
it can't be traced if
if you come to the agency demanding to
see your file
and if they have a soft file on you
instead of a 201
you'll never get it they may have a
manila folder in there with with reams
of documents about you
and you'll never get access to it there
were times when i
said well
let's just get out of the cia you know
bob really you're making a decision
which is
it's it's getting to the point where
it's going to be the cia or it's going
to be our marriage and he chose the cia
what an opportunity i was being asked to
watch the ball the angolan ball game
from the outset how we got into it
what we uh they're all the
rationalization and justification as
well as the decision-making processes
i was to watch this game not from the
50-yard line but from from the the field
itself a player coach i mean go into
angola and get in the action where the
where the people are groveling in the
dust and losing their lives as well as
the high policy planning sessions in
washington
and i was delighted to have the
opportunity to to sacrifice a year of my
life to see just how the us government
does this sort of thing
the ci went into angola in july of 1975.
we started out with six million dollars
and eventually the total budget was 31
million dollars
the first effort was arms that were sent
from america to kinshasa in u.s air
force c-141 planes
then from kinshasa we hauled the arms
into a goal and smaller
the total was about 1 500 tons of arms
30 000 rifles and small rockets and
mortars
our funds and arms were going to two of
the three angola factions one of them
headed up by holden roberto who had had
a relationship with us for about 15
years and to cevindi who had not been
well known by the cia
he had the sole virtue of being in
opposition to the mpla and we were
determined to oppose president mobutsu
zaire wanted this program
we bribed him we gave him two million
seven hundred fifty thousand dollars ci
officers went in as advisers and
trainers they were called intelligence
gatherers but in fact uh they were
preparing our allies for combat
i fled to san salvador on january 16th
what did the enemy do in san salvador
you mean what i saw
with
these americans what did they look like
were they white were they black
describe them
no it
there were not enough cia advisors to
make a great deal of difference however
and we hired european mercenaries and we
tried to hire white angolan refugees to
go back in as mercenaries fighting on
our side
the cia collaborated with the south
africans and it was not officially
ordered by the national security council
but there was liaison at all levels the
cia was nervous about the role the
senate might play in this war senator
clark on the foreign relations committee
made a trip to africa to review the
situation a fact-finding trip to report
to the senate
the cia watched him
with some apprehension to see that he
didn't get information we didn't want
him to have
the senate led by senator clark shut
down the angola program in december of
75
while the senate was shutting us down a
cuban army eventually of 10 to 15 000
combat soldiers to make 21 aircraft
tanks
i just swept over the fnla in united
and we lost decisively a victoria
of angola
nevertheless i think we could have
won the thing if we had gone in very
quickly when i went out there and came
back i recommended that i said the
forces are about equal right now
and if we go in with immediate abundant
support we can win we can take luanda
by that i met tactical heir and american
advisers
put in a several hundred troops very
quickly and put in some of these really
monstrous weapons
airplanes you know that fly around
shooting 8 000 rounds a minute down and
you'd have been in the london just like
that it appears from what you said that
you advocated that the united states
should go into angola
with large weapons lots of firepower a
small detachment of americans and that
your plan was rejected and that was the
final straw that did it for you
no that's very definitely a
misunderstanding yesterday we got
distracted
we were into that and then we didn't get
a chance to pursue it probably changing
of cameras or something
i was sick at my stomach that we were
going into angola i was this i was
depressed
that the agency would be letting itself
get dragged into another paramilitary
adventure
that quickly after vietnam and it would
obviously not succeed
we couldn't possibly stay with it
the senate the press the public wouldn't
be about to let us escalate something up
to the level that it would have a chance
of winning
and
it would be highly damaging to the
nation and to
the
cia particularly
to to let ourselves get dragged into
some such a thing
once and at the outset when they offered
me this job
then i had a choice of
you know what do i do do i participate
or do i resign or do i quietly lobby for
a
some other job and let someone else run
the angola program
and my decision was that i was going to
stay with the program because it was too
interesting to see how does the united
states get dragged into these things and
how does the ci conduct them once it's
in them i don't think anybody could
could turn down that kind of an
opportunity just
to know
that it's not what some newspapermen is
telling you what happens when he doesn't
really know himself
it's what's really happening you were
there running it so i decided to
participate
and in order to make sure that i
remained on the inside i remained a good
good soldier throughout the whole thing
i did not balk or fight it until we got
into phases that i thought were just
beyond the pale such as alliances with
the south africans and mercenaries for
example when i went to angola i was sent
out there to come back with a military
assessment and uh that's what i
recommended when i got back if you guys
want to win we can do it
a dramatic weapon a horrendous weapon if
you will
against the mpla at that time would have
just brushed them aside it would have
decimated him it would have wiped them
out
and uh the fnla would have been into
rwanda in a few moments time well
suppose they had taken your military
recommendation
how would you felt
i would have uh stayed as task force
chief and participated i
i if you're gonna do some you know if
you're gonna learn french
or a foreign language the least you can
do with your poor pronunciation is speak
out
and i think it's uh
there are certain things that are
criminal
uh but you compound it by losing
if you're going to go into angola if you
have some national compulsion to go into
angola at least the united states
position would be much stronger if you
won
and
if they had
accepted my recommendation at that point
i would have been
much happier uh if if they had gone
ahead and won than i was with the
contemptible
middle ground that they followed
the overall life overseas is very
agreeable i think it's one of the things
that a lot of men in the cia want to
they want to stay out overseas it's kind
of a colonialist existence
there are lots of servants and the life
is very easy the housing is very
adequate if not plush
we had about six white kids in our class
and then um
you know everybody just blended in
it was you know a little bit of um
like
racism or whatever on the teacher's part
and that you know she thought that the
black kids were a little deprived and
everything
but
you know in the schools everybody got
along it was a pleasant place for kids
to grow up i mean that you're living
with the elite of that society in terms
of education
basically and experiences the people
who've traveled and people who who've
been involved in a lot of experiences in
life you know ambassadors and people who
are running the country
and
the
diplomats in different embassies
and so they're sharp people they're
intelligent people and they're they're
well bred generally so the conduct is
relatively high a sense of culture
when we were in africa i don't remember
everything but i didn't i don't remember
so much about the school
i mean like when we were there we'd go
on our safaris and we climbed kenya and
ran all over the place and we're just
ambitious doing everything he was a
little older and longer-legged so he
could go on hunting safaris mel was just
a year about a year too young he just
couldn't quite
pull it off although he did a lot of the
jogging with us
that's cheating he's supposed to give us
a little bit to get
to get pumped up
one more good one
this is about
90 pounds
come on
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's a highly competitive business and
you're working under stress
you go to the same cocktail parties that
the state department officers go to and
then a dinner party after the cocktail
party but in between you go meet an
agent and you pay him off and you get a
receipt
and
you rush up to the embassy and stow the
stuff so it won't fall out of your
pocket at the dinner party or something
and then you go to the dinner party and
then after the dinner party you go run
another errand
and
this goes on
day in and day out saturdays sundays
holidays
and when you begin to see that the the
organization as a whole is very sloppy
and poorly run and the standards are
very low you're it's hard to stay
motivated it's hard to keep thinking
it's worthwhile and you really get to a
state where you just
just really don't want to have to lock
everything about your professional life
in a safe
and lie to all of the people you know
about who you really are and what you're
really doing and what your real dreams
and aspirations and promotions are
and
be able to complain to them about your
failures or
our problems well i realize now that the
business of the cia is to go out and to
corrupt
individuals in their in place in their
own countries
and
that this is something that
corrupts oneself
this was going against his upbringing
which was a strong christian
very moral background
and he was coming into conflict with
himself
hating himself angry with himself you
know i would like to to present myself
as a man of intense principle who saw
bad things and immediately resigned and
discussed but my career was obviously
going quite well
i had the prestige of people coming to
me for jobs coming to me for advice
inviting me to she wanted to play tennis
with me
this is you know obviously human
satisfaction i was not yet
in top management i couldn't really give
away a lot of jobs but i could speak on
behalf of someone
my income was about thirty three
thousand dollars a year and ten years i
could retire on a twenty one thousand
dollar a year pension for the rest of my
life
i had total security was it the thought
that you would be continuing to do
things like the vietnam involvement
mingle and the angle and involvement
that you thought was
immoral or
counterproductive at least well what i
tried to do was to psych myself into
going back to africa as a chief of
station in some place like cartoon for
example which would have been a nice
post for my grade
and just not
push
covert operations very much if something
came along it was just sort of
irresistible some agent that just had to
be recruited will let an officer in my
station recruit him but basically just
play a lot of tennis and let the
paychecks come in
this is
a traditionally what uh burned out
senior case officers do and i muddled
and and waffled and vacillated and
rationalized
for about eight months before i could
tear myself away
i i don't really look at it as uh
taking that much uh guts to quit i just
sort of didn't have any choice by
november and december i had intense
pains in my abdomen which were obviously
the precursors of a stomach ulcer from
the internal conflict
of wanting to hang on to this career but
not respecting it i had requested many
times that bob just drop out of the cia
just get out and start life in you
someplace
he wasn't able to do so when i asked him
to but now
he has he's seen even more since our
divorce
and
yes i do feel vindicated when a man
comes back and says you were right all
along everything you ever said was right
everything you ever said about everybody
who walked into our house was right what
lessons did you learn from your dad's
experience well of course it brings up
values just
all over the place
and that that i mean i could go you
could
break up on that a whole lot
but you know i'm listening to him right
now i'm learning
this is
something else what's your reaction to
cia now well i think up high they're
slobs and then you're down in the lower
when you get down into the um people are
actually out in the field
then they would do the working you know
it makes me a very inefficient
crooked
really sloppy organization
i was not a man at peace with himself
and since i resigned i do not feel in a
position of conflict
i feel in a position of being in peace
with myself morally
uh
for our news coverage tonight we're
going to show you some clippings taken
from the network television news of the
quote discovery of the russian troops in
cuba and we will show you the way that
the television network news handled
covered and interpreted this event and
the political ramifications and how they
were covered then we will discuss with
john
if indeed the full story was told on
network news of the cuban russian
relationship and we will also see what
distortions there were in the television
coverage and we'll let john comment and
give another interpretation of the
political implications of this so-called
event cuba is obstructing the senate's
work on salt to budget and military
planning
as a result the administration is
negotiating with both the ussr and the
u.s senate
according to congressional sources both
negotiations are serious
with soviet ambassador dobrinan
and with senate leaders serious and
intricate
politics on cuba are more murky in the
senate than in the kremlin
the administration must strike one deal
with the soviet union but many deals
here
with sam nunn demanding a five percent
increase in u.s military spending before
he will vote for salt too
but cuba has frozen salt too
the administration must negotiate with
frank church who says no salt until all
the soviet combat troops leave cuba
carter can make no deal with the soviet
union about the troops without dealing
with powerful scoop jackson who wants
troops and jets and submarines out
before he'll consider salt and he won't
even do that without a 5 military budget
increase
that brings carter into entirely new
negotiations with budget chairman musky
who opposes any major spending increase
and according to the white house press
secretary decisions were made about how
to deal with the problem posed by those
soviet combat forces in cuba there was
no further public comment on the nature
of those decisions however here is a
report from our white house
correspondent sam donaldson
president carter may decide to counter
the soviet combat presence in cuba by
stepping up an american military
presence both in the caribbean and
elsewhere in the world unless of course
the soviets take steps on their own to
change the status quo as the president
has demanded
no one here will confirm that such a
decision is in the works but the
president's own words on this subject
ten days ago point to such an approach
we do have the right to insist
that the soviet union respect our
interests and our concerns
if the soviet union expects us to
respect their sensibilities and their
concerns
otherwise
relations between our two countries
will inevitably be adversely affected
what the president was clearly saying
was that if the russians don't change
the status quo by taking action
themselves the united states will change
it through its own actions not by
provoking a war-like confrontation but
perhaps by stepping up u.s combat forces
in the caribbean which would serve to
neutralize any possible threat from cuba
and perhaps by challenging soviet
interest elsewhere through a mix of
military and economic moves that while
not directly threatening moscow would
adversely affect russian concerns the
president said one advisor is not going
to paper over those troops the status
quo will be changed
sam donaldson abc news the white house
this is john scaling top administration
officials have now started to consider a
wide range of military and economic
pressures against the soviets among the
most sensitive is the possibility of
helping armed china with modern weapons
a step that would be sure to alarm the
kremlin any such move would come later
after other less dangerous decisions
such as sharply reducing american grain
shipments now at a record level it is
estimated that american wheat and
feedstock exports to the soviets will
surpass 2 billion dollars this year
administration leaders would be most
reluctant to order such cutbacks because
of the humanitarian aspect involved in
such sales but if necessary such
decisions would be made say informants
along with a sharp reduction in
shipments of american machinery and high
technology items
military countermeasures would seek to
avoid any direct military threat to the
soviets the steps that would be
considered are reinforcing american
ground and united states units overseas
plus helping anti-soviet forces near the
russian border was told today that
unless those soviet troops are removed
from cuba there's virtually no chance
for senate approval of the new strategic
arms treaty with moscow the grim warning
came at a white house meeting with
congressional leaders president's got a
tough problem
i said before the only thing he can't do
with this russian troop problem is
nothing he's got to do something this is
jimmy carter's challenge
i think we've used too much time i think
the matter should have been dealt with
by now well john you were telling me
about the situation uh you know whether
it was you were in cuba or a friend was
in cuba when the word came down the
to cover it yeah a friend of a friend of
mine an acquaintance of mine that i've
met since i got out of the ci was
passing through town and he had been
there covering the non-aligned nations
conference he was a writer
he is a writer yes working on a magazine
in
in washington a controversial magazine
but he was there as a reporter
with the reporters covering the
conference
they got the the various reporters got
instructions from their offices in
washington and new york to find out
about the soviets in cuba
and they sent back messages according to
him all of them saying you've got to be
kidding this has got to be some kind of
a grand put on
and they got terse messages back from
their headquarters saying it's it's the
big story of right now do it find out
about the soviets in cuba and they
couldn't believe it it was it was an
international joke literally now well
let's back up a big step and note what
what nobody brought out and they
certainly could have
and that's that the
the subject the issue of soviet troops
in cuba was a spin-off an evolution of a
ci operation to disrupt and manipulate
the non-aligned nations conference
fidel castro was managing this
conference is hosting it
on in cuba near america which which is a
difference and he's the old anathema to
the cia the cia tried to kill him so
many times
unsuccessfully 20 years unable to rid
itself
rid the united states of this communist
leader on our shores
and this year the the non-aligned
nations conferences meeting in havana
hosted by castro the cia went all out
the thing they seized on as an issue to
discredit castro was to make him appear
to be
not non-aligned he's aligned with the
soviet union
which is probably true it's it's
probably his achilles heel as an online
nation's leader is that he is aligned
with the soviet union
how better could the cia bring this out
than to make a big issue of soviet
troops in cuba
and it's been leaked out if you read
these various articles in time magazine
in the new york times in the washington
post and elsewhere you notice that
it is admitted that the ci was working
with the national security council the
national security adviser brzezinski
on the the subject of the conference the
upcoming conference and they did seize
on the presence of soviet troops in cuba
as an issue and in exactly during the
conference they make this this dramatic
announcement of soviet troops in uh in
cuba
now
what is brought out in bits and pieces
but not very well by the media and
covering this by the statements that
were quoted is that
there was no threatening soviet presence
in cuba no one at any point pretended
that the u.s was a national security was
being jeopardized by a soviet force that
could invade
florida or puerto rico or anywhere else
it was a trivial 2000 men approximately
a lot of semantics were played on
whether or not they were combat troops
well
i would react by saying that they were
in fact combat troops but combat troops
are also instructors so the soviets may
be telling the truth there
but
they are infantry troops but they are
not assault troops even president carter
in one of his speeches admitted this
they didn't have they they do not have
the delivery capability the the ships
airplanes helicopters however to to move
from cuba to florida or puerto rico or
somewhere else they're not assault
troops they don't have an aggressive
posture or capability they don't have
the weapons that would go with an
assault unit
the press
dramatized this issue by talking and you
you notice these commentators the the
drama that they would get in their
voices where they would say soviet
troops in cuba you know you want to sit
up and get nervous
if they had said
this tiny soviet force in cuba every
time they brought it up or something
like that it would have put it into its
true perspective
something else
well john do you think they manufactured
the story then that we've known that
there have been soviet troops in cuba
since 1962. definitely there was
something like 40 000 troops at that
time and most were withdrawn but there's
been two or three thousand troops there
continuing the whole time and and vance
is the secretary of state's first the
for the administration's first
announcement of this as being an issue
objected to the status quo he did not
object to the introduction of soviet
troops into cuba he said the status quo
is unacceptable because
he knew that the soviets knew and the
cubans knew that we knew that they had
been there the whole time there was
nothing new about this issue the only
thing that was new was the non-aligned
nations conference happening right but
did the media adequately point out that
no new cute russian troops were actually
recently placed in cuba didn't they give
the impression from the news clippings
that this was something new something
threatening something dangerous as if
russia had recently
put a whole
flock of new troops there that suddenly
posed a threat so this is this is really
distortion of the grossest
magnitude because it's exercising the
american people it's jeopardizing salt
notice also that every one of the the
senators and and other individuals that
are quoted there has some
major vested interest in making an issue
out of this except
perhaps senator byrd
salt won't go said church unless the
troops are out and presidential hopeful
baker said he won't be able to remain
silent if the troops aren't out soon now
he either has the guts to do something
about it or he doesn't
there's no need to
look at this as though it's a crisis i
was here in the 1962 crisis i've been
hearing some pretty tense moments
but there's no crisis here
scoop jackson is the original hawk
always clamoring for more arms and a
more dramatic u.s military posture
baker of course in goldwater
traditionally
critics of the democratic administration
baker with his own presidential
aspirations both of them conservative
both of them looking for issues that
they can stir it up to
to egg the administration on to
challenge the soviets to sort of go to
war
the hawks
were able to play this issue into
a situation which which apparently is
going to lead has led and is going to
lead to an escalation of military
activity in the caribbean and greater
defense spending we now have in in the
press
today 2 000 more u.s marines being put
into guantanamo bay on cuban soil
and other marine military maneuvers in
the caribbean
it's been a it was a field day for the
for the hawks
dunn is another hawk 5
military budget
increase
frank church of course is a traditional
liberal but he's in jeopardy of losing
his position in the new elections
his state i believe it's idaho has
turned conservative under him and so he
was back when this was
launched he he he was advised of it over
a scrambled telephone
while he was back in idaho campaigning
and uh he his reaction is has been
quoted abundantly that he said i can't
sit on this i can't keep this secret
soviets in cuba i've got to come out
with it
and the answer from the administration
was we realized that meaning obviously
they called him while he was home while
he was on this ultra conservative kick
to give him ammunition so he would bring
it out and make an issue of it
carter's
objectives are fairly clear hit at the
point that
crisis non-crisis broke he had never
been lower in the polls his political
future was and still is very much in
doubt
and he needed some issue that he could
some crisis or preferably
awful sounding non-crisis that he could
thump his chest and show how macho he is
in handling this non-crisis and so he
did but didn't this backfire in some
ways against carter because because he
wasn't able to effectively do anything
about it that is he couldn't get the
russians to remove the troops that it
made him look weak again
the network's made
this is what surprised me by looking at
the coverage of it
the networks constantly made carter look
like a fool
the president sought counsel from the
congressional delegation to the
distinguished jacob javits mr carter
said what would you do
reply
you mean you called us here at 8 30 in
the morning to ask us what we would do
what are you going to do senators and
congressmen were told the u.s asked the
soviet union if the troops were combat
troops
answer from moscow no
the u.s asked if they would take the
troops out anyway answer no
another answer to the same question is
expected within a few days inquiry how
many days
president two or three days
vance not that fast
javits can we have another meeting yes
within a week
vance not that fast
that is what you call your basic linkage
between cuba and salt
even though sources said the meeting was
told the united states still does not
know why the soviet troops are there
and we do not know exactly how serious
it all is
another congressional leader president
accused the president of trying to have
it both ways of being hard on one hand
and soft on the other according to this
source the meeting was not very
enlightening or satisfying senate
democratic majority leader robert byrd
didn't even bother to attend the meeting
with the president byrd claimed that he
had received a briefing from secretary
vance last night the result of today's
meeting the president did win some more
time however he did not generate much
confidence in his leadership
the president hopes this policy will
convince hardliners particularly those
in the senate who are holding the salt
treaty hostage that he has effectively
neutralized the russian troops while at
the same time proving anew that he does
not panic in a crisis and risk general
war
but already the president's plan has hit
one tiny snag mr carter wanted to go on
television sunday night and word of that
leaked so widely in washington that one
afternoon newspaper here headlined the
carter talk on cuba on sunday then the
white house discovered that sunday was
the high holy jewish holiday yom kippur
and so in some confusion it rescheduled
the speech for monday night
sam donaldson abc news the white house
they gave a lot of tv network coverage
to connelly
and baker and these right-wing
republicans attacking carter for being
soft so i think carter really lost
politically
on this one also after the
the speech that carter made where he
outlined his plan immediately the
headlines and the 10 o'clock news were
russian troops to stay in cuba as if
carter had not really done anything and
therefore failed to be a strong
leader well isn't there a certain
justice in that though because this this
whole thing started with an operation
brzezinski and the cia
juned up to embarrass cuba and the
soviets
and but president they worked for
president carter the the ci is part of
the white house
and and
and carter uh permitted it apparently
encouraged it to be brought brought out
and made public and made into an
international issue and
in that sense it's backfiring on him as
a certain amount of justice he had
secretary vance make the statements and
say make an issue out of it throw the
gauntlet down say the status quo is
unacceptable
and the amateurishness of this
administration was was shown right then
and there
in that the status quo was unchangeable
by the united states
except this this very weak solution he
came up in the end well we can't do
anything about the soviets in cuba
so
we'll increase our own military activity
around you always wonder
how
much something like this
was planned ahead of time since it had
so much of an effect of encouraging the
hawks
and leader leading to greater military
activity and spending how much of it was
was
determined ahead of time let's let's
make an issue of the soviet troops there
so we can get into this defense spending
particularly since they've known about
it for 17 years since they've known
about it for 17 years well i noticed
frequently that they would toss around
the cia as well we have good
intelligence i got a briefing by
stanfield turner blah blah they would be
bringing it in as if that would
automatically give the stamp of
expertise on it
i was just in a briefing
with stanfield turner the head of the
cia a few moments ago
and he believes that
those troops are not there
just to train cubans
however we do not know the mission of
those troops early this morning national
security council members including cia
director turner and secretary of state
vance arrived to continue talks with the
president which went on here until late
last night about senator baker's
suggestion that the president now
release intelligence photographs of the
soviet troops in cuba abc news
diplomatic correspondent barry dunsmore
reports the state department will oppose
doing that while negotiations are still
underway but if the talks break down
release of the evidence might be a good
idea
it's amazing how they would dare to do
that when you have this history of
incredible endless intelligence failures
by the cia in crisis after crisis after
crisis the cia coming up with faulty or
false information
and for them to cite stansfield turner
in a situation like this remember the
last u.s cuban confrontation
where
president carter was calling
president castro a liar and vice versa
was a year and a half ago
at the time the katangis invaded the
shabbat
and president carter said that we had
intelligence that it was a cuban
operation and
castro said it absolutely was not
a cuban operation that it was katangi's
and cuba had nothing to do with it and
president carter did much as they had
there he had ci you know the cia had
information proving it
eventually it was resolved by some
senators going down to havana and
meeting with castro
at his invitation and he convinced them
that there was reasonable doubt and they
went back and demanded and were shown
the ci's intelligence
and the 17 senators walked out of that
meeting and said it didn't prove
the presence of cuba behind that
invasion at all
in other words in yet another situation
president carter uh was not telling the
truth he was misinformed and he was
distorting the information lying if you
will
and fidel castro was telling the truth
what amazes me once again is the
absolute distortion of grameko
speech and the russians position
the russians admitted they had troops
there and that they've been there for a
long time grumeko said you know this is
a foolish put up job and let's forget
about it and get on with the business of
salt and yet then the senators would
come and say grimiko's lying he's an
absolute liar he called it like it was
soviet foreign minister andre gramico
today dismissed the american charge with
a short blunt demand forget it in his
speech the united nations general
assembly mr gramiko said it was all part
of a campaign to spread lies about the
policies of cuba and the soviet union
but the truth
is that this propaganda
is totally without foundation in reality
and our advice on this score is simple
it is high time
that you honestly admit
that this whole matter is artificial and
proclaim it
to be closed
although mr grimiko did not even mention
the presence of soviet troops in cuba it
was clear this is what he was talking
about just two weeks ago the soviet
union admitted it does have troops in
cuba but only to train the cubans in
soviet military hardware that their
duties and numbers have not changed in
17 years and that any charges that
organized soviet combat units have
arrived in cuba are totally groundless
and mr gromiko insisted that there's no
reason for concern
the soviet union
and other countries of the socialist
community have never threatened anybody
nor are they threatening anybody now
this is lou giafi abc news at the united
nations suzanne compton at the capitol
where senators who have seen american
intelligence photos say gramico is lying
i'm astonished
there is simply no basis for doubting
that the soviet union that the russians
have
a fully equipped fully manned
combat brigade in cuba i would hope that
the president now would consider
releasing the very very reliable
intelligence data we have including
aerial and satellite photography
to conclusively show that there are
russian combat troops in cuba
each senator pointed out that gromika
was involved in another cuban dispute
the 1962 missile crisis
i think the the president
really has to be firm in this
and just remind the american people that
this is the same mr gromiko who lied
about missiles
he was caught red-handed
and i regret that mr grumiko has seen
fit
to state a ball-face lie
that's what it is
gramico's intervention has had a
chilling effect on the strategic arms
treaty with the soviets a growing number
of senators including the man in control
of the treaty foreign relations chairman
frank church
say that unless the president can soon
certify that the russian combat forces
have been dismantled the salt treaty
will be put on ice it was not a good day
today for the united states at the
united nations
absolutely he called it like it was he
said that they were there he said they
were not
assault troops
but they were there for training and
certainly we have troops all over the
world that are there to help install
our and train and use
our our military equipment the hardware
we've installed we had for many years
this huge unit in in arizaba we have of
course 5 000 troops on the soviet border
in turkey
these troops have no capability of
invading russia for heaven's sake but
they are combat troops they've all been
trained in how to shoot rifles and
whatnot
and i would say that the only two people
i saw in there
who seemed to be candidly
caught three i guess calling it like it
was
was senator byrd
who said it was a non-crisis
gromeko who it appeared to me called it
like it was said you're making something
out of nothing for your own purposes and
then fidel castro also calling it like
it was and andrew young also and andrew
young yes
which we call training center
estanco
in conformity with the spirit of the
agreement
on october of that year
and within the status quo that was set
up as a result of the october crisis why
has he brought this problem the right
now to create a situation
that carter's uh situation is in a
crisis
not given the right
to place peace into a crisis
receiving the world public
andrew young bowed out as a diplomat
speaking his mind as usual last night he
spoke to 5 000 blacks and at a time when
the administration has been saying it's
gravely concerned over those soviet
combat troops in cuba young ridiculed
the threat
if the russians made a move against us
our defenses are strong enough to ignore
and wipe out and obliterate some 3000
cubans and i mean russians in cuba what
the hell can they do to the united
states of america
that is a totally irrelevant political
issue that has nothing to do with the
national security of this nation
more relevant young said is inflation
and unemployment more of a threat than
troops in cuba then young philosophized
about what he thinks is wrong with
foreign policy
it's not some awful strategic concept
decided by some folks that ain't never
fought no wars don't know nothing about
suffering never been poor
and essentially in
isolate themselves in some ivory tower
writing papers and theorizing to each
other
those are the folks
those essentially other folk that have
created the mess that the world is now
in andrew young's beautiful comment
and the other people wow
john don't you think that the network
news is irresponsible in failing to give
this broader context for the story in
leaving out the fact that this was
a story based on leaks that really gave
no new information and the way they
played this up night after night and
gave all these hawks such a
pervasive coverage
you know our our enemies overseas we
talk about communist censorship of the
press
and the communists talk about our
censorship of the press or our press
working for the government
and as we sit here we find this an
incredible charge from from the
communists because we know that we have
freedom of the press
you can go out and start a newspaper
with a mimeograph machine and print more
or less what you want and you probably
won't be eliminated the next day by the
fbi although that has been known to
happen
but
the fact is that while you can't claim
plausibly and i wouldn't that the new
york times or the washington post our
time magazine or newsweek the biggies
are actually controlled by the
administration not in the sense of the
administration calling them up and
saying here's our line on this issue
everybody do it
the press plays directly into the hands
of the administration it's the voice of
a given administration the press has
gotten us into
incredible situations in the world
devastating situations in the world
such as the vietnam war
if the if the vietnam war if the press
had been
conscientious in nailing the
administration on its lies and
distortions during the vietnam war
during the build-up of the vietnam war
it never would have happened
if they had balked then if they had had
interviews with people and then had
someone come on
afterwards saying unfortunately all of
that's untrue see the press tries it
claims it presents the facts and facts
are are if president carter or scoop
jackson or goldwater someone makes a
speech
that is a fact that he made that speech
and said those words
now the fact that all of those words
were false
is never clarified to the public
so the administration can use the press
to to put out whatever it wants to on a
given situation and the press will play
along for the sense of drama as they say
to sell newspapers so you have crises
like this that could never have existed
if the press had nailed him at the
outset and said this is nonsense it's a
non-crisis there's another irony here in
that during this very period the
russians
went to east germany in a very big
flourish they said they were going to
take 20 000 russian troops out of east
germany and we were going to withdraw a
lot of their forces from central europe
and this was hardly covered there were
only seconds of coverage whereas this
seemed to be a major change
in soviet uh policy and a potential thaw
in europe which could be much more
important than this non-event in cuba
and yet
this was barely mentioned this is how
the press can create some stories and
how they don't even
cover you've got to you've got to
remember and this is why i titled my
book in search of enemies
it's necessary to our system of
government
to have people to oppose and people to
hate
if you'll look for example
i believe it was yesterday president
carter just finished a small political
swing
made
repeated statements about cuba
cuba's aggressive posture cuba's
military the the cuba being the most
militarized country in the world
etc
surely we have things that are more
important
than cuba to to this nation right now
the collapsing economy the galloping
inflation
all of the various uh minority groups
that are still suffering persecution in
this country he he nevertheless he
focuses on cuba and makes them into an
enemy which they have no desire to be
so that we've got somebody to hate to
oppose so that we've got an excuse to
thump our chest and build up our
military machine and he's doing this
obviously as a a major element in his
presidential campaign
searching for enemies looking for people
that don't want to fight us
that we we need to have somebody to
oppose i think there's also kind of a
long range thing that they're looking
forward to here also
you read some books and see some
statements by
the high muckety mucks and they complain
that
the vietnam war has had such a
devastating effect on public opinion
that they can't wheel and deal around
the world now like they used to because
public opinion would not allow it people
would hit the streets again so i think
this is part of an overall policy of
trying to whip up the cold war rhetoric
and look for enemies like you say so
that people will become hawkish and
accept a more
militant stance and activist stance
around the world
as a matter of fact it resulted in the
poll which was mentioned by ap and nbc
associated press poll shows americans by
three to one want assault treaty held up
by the senate until the russian troops
are moved out of cuba
66 percent said hold up the treaty 22
said don't the others didn't know
john how would you comment on carter's
speech on this incident where he claimed
that cuba was a puppet a satellite of
the soviet union it was an economic
failure do you think that's an accurate
account well you notice fidel castro was
on
60 minutes
the night before president carter's big
speech on this subject
and he called president carter dishonest
on this this subject
and then the next night
carter went on television and it was
almost as though he set out to prove
castro right
his presentation of the facts was so
distorted and he left out these these
glaring omissions that would give some
balance to the thing that would have
explained it and put it into its
perspective
things like
cuba's
long-standing and repeated
offer overture to us to normal normalize
relations
which we have consistently spurned
the presence he did not mention the
presence of of our marine corps base on
cuban soil
now mind you if the soviets had troops
on u.s soil or cuban troops on u.s soil
it would be a different thing but we
actually maintain a marine corps base on
cuban soil
he made a big thing out of the
cuba's dependency economic dependency on
the soviet union and he called it cuba
the economic failure of communism
he didn't point out that we've had a
20-year economic war against cuba that
it's a long ways from russia and it's
very close to us
this war has included of course the the
assassination attempts on the leader and
the propaganda efforts
to to to disrupt the morale of the
country but aside from all that
projects to destroy their sugar crops
and and cuba is almost totally dependent
on its sugar for one thing
a blockade of cuba for many many years
embargo on the sale of many things to
cuba we did everything we could to make
them into our enemy
and to force them into the arms of the
soviet union to force them to be
dependent on the soviet union we could
have taken the opposite policy and tried
to help them get established
economically so that they could be part
of the community of nations and not be
aligned with the soviet union we pushed
them into the arms of the soviet union
he didn't bother to point that out this
it's the greatest irony i think the
hardest thing for americans to to
understand and realize and face and
accept is that
our presidents have now a tradition of
being the most duplicious of any world
leaders our presidents lie the most
as a matter of policy because of the
secrecy establishment now
it was it was absolute proof of the
putting of the whole thing about the cia
this was another ci operation that got
out of hand a rogue elephant they like
to call them that put
that it jeopardized salt too and put the
united states in the position of being
ridiculed in the eyes of the world and
preoccupied our government for three
weeks until carter finally did you
notice how when he was on television how
he kept smirking
he would be talking very seriously about
all these heavy things and he'd kind of
give his his little his little grin he
couldn't repress it because he knew
what a joke this whole thing was
there was there was no crisis
but at the same time it had become a
crisis in the sense that salt too was at
stake
well al slavinski is going to join us
now and we'll
proceed with
more in-depth discussion of this and
other
other items which might be on your mind
it's clear to me this is a pseudo issue
but i'm not clear of how the cia is
behind it okay you have to read between
the lines only a little bit to
understand the ci's role because it has
been stated
in the last few weeks
i
would be more alert to what these
statements meant having been part of
these things before but every three
years there's the the online nations
conference
and every three years nine months before
the conference the ci mounts a massive
operation to discredit disrupt and
manipulate this conference
in
in 19 whenever it was 1970
the big issue was china was trying to
get into the united nations
and we
were leaning in the direction of talking
directly to china
but the the thrust of the non-aligned
nations conference operation
was to get all of the delegates possible
to to oppose endorsing the entry of
china into the united nations i was
involved in that when i had an agent who
was an intellectual third world figure
who was a
an official in his government who could
go to this conference and so i was
leaned on by headquarters every station
ci station in the world gets these
cables saying not just do you have
anyone who would go but they go through
your files back at headquarters and find
out what agents you have and come in and
say send in our intellect to this place
and tell him what to say
and i got out my agent and and leaned on
him and said uh
this is the line you've got to take
vis-a-vis china and he said wait a
minute he said wait a minute he said
my country is very poor
we need china we need a relation with
china
you're ordering me to sabotage my
country's interests for one of your
political ploys when everybody can see
that the united states is in the process
of going to bed with china in her own
economic interest
he said how can i do that and ours too
and so i i went back to headquarters and
said that he was not responsive
and so they sort of put an x on how well
he stood as a disciplined agent and
wrote you know little things about you
know i didn't have complete control of
all my agents well we shouldn't really
dismiss the cuban thing as being a
mickey mouse situation well here's what
happens there's going to be an increase
in defense spending because of it
there's going to be increased military
presidents it's it's it has turned out
it's a tempest and a teapot but it won
it jeopardized salt i think that'll blow
over and people get over that but it has
le it is wound up when when we were
moving in the direction of support for
salt and a reduction of strategic
weapons and military posturing
that's that's what these treaties should
be about
it has wound up to be a victory for the
hawks in in the defense department and
and in the cia and also this this is
kind of reminiscent of the days when
hoover would create a threat
and go out and stomp it down and get
more money from congress in the process
isn't the cia doing the same thing
exactly although i don't knowing them as
as i feel i do as i did and i believe i
still do
i don't think that they are
they have enough mind about there's
enough of a of them an intellect driving
what they do
they always have these non-align nations
conference this time it's a biggie
because it's in cuba and it's the old ci
nemesis castro is running it this is the
man the ci tried eight times to kill
he's tried to destroy
cuba's sugar crops and whatnot we've
forced the ci's forced him to be totally
dependent on the soviet union
economically and he has he has stuck his
finger in the ci's eye over the years
time and time again and gotten away with
it and he's doing it again 90 miles from
our own shores so the ci was obviously
incensed and and by that when you say ci
in that context you mean the
intelligence establishment because there
are people who don't work in the
language like the big new brzezinski for
example that don't work in the cia but
they're part of the same complex
and it's now it's it's been admitted by
the white house that uh brzezinski
met with the cia 40 committee meetings
are the operations advisory group
meetings with the ci director
and ordered the ci to focus on cuba
and focus on their vulnerabilities and
focus on soviets in cuba
and this was this they admitted that
this began last march
and so they focused on their operation
to discredit castro
tell me
how have you changed since the last time
we saw you you had written the book in
search of enemies
and it was doing well
and people were talking perhaps about
doing a movie and you were trying to get
on the
lecture series have all these good
things come about or
as the cia been after your
defective fanny what you know
you know i don't i i really don't feel
that i've changed one bit through this
whole experience except
a bit of broadening a bit more
confidence in
mankind on one side and
a bit more cynical perhaps on the other
yes i've lectured all over the nation
three dozen times i guess on
different universities i've appeared on
television
in every corner of the nation
but i still feel like the same old
country
how have you been received
and reception that's where
the the experience has been so rewarding
you know inside the ci you're very much
have the feeling of belonging to a
religious order
that's not how you would verbalize it
inside the cia but that's the effect
you you live with cia people you
socialize with cia people
and you have quite a feeling that
outsiders the rest of the world are
hostile
and misguided
and that inside the ci you're safe and
you're with people you can trust and
people who view the world correctly
and it was the most refreshing thing
about leaving the cia and getting
outside and meeting people in the press
and the media and universities around
the nation
was to find how many really decent
people they are there are
who who are working hard for things they
believe in and are quite responsive to
someone who's made a gesture
as as i have to
a moral gesture
and
lecturing for example i've as i say i've
lectured i guess three dozen times i
haven't counted but many many times and
i have yet to have one lecture
that did not go
hours beyond the prescribed time even
when i had to catch an airplane they
would still keep me for hours
a lecture you know would be scheduled
for an hour an hour and a half and 15
minutes of questions and it would go on
in fact
until midnight one o'clock with people
asking questions and the discussion just
flowing
and then more often than not go
somewhere to drink beer and talk on
until three four in the morning the
interest is extremely high
in this subject of of the secret
government and governmental abuses the
encroachment of the government on
individuals inside our society but also
on
on the peoples of the world
speaking of which john have you been
contacted or pressured by the cia there
was a threat that they were going to sue
they had sued frank schnepp for
publishing his book about the cia and
you were worried last time you were here
that you might be sued also have you
heard anything from the cia recently
when they when they sued snap which was
spring a year ago
his book came out a few months before
mine did
which i
regret
because i i think my book was a much
better book in a moral sense not quality
of writing or anything but
the government got to him first just
before my book came out and sued him
and made snep a test case
then my book came out and unofficially
they were you know talking in washington
it was clear that the government was
frustrated
that they moved against him instead of
me and i was frustrated because there
was going to be a snap precedent instead
of a stockpile precedent
and i think i would have put up a fight
that would have been much more effective
for this reason
snap believes in the cia
he believes in covert action against
the third world countries
he believes in secrecy his only
complaint was that in vietnam there was
a scandal at the end and it was covered
up in the evacuation of vietnam
i believe that the cia is is a
moral uh tragedy
and that it's discredited the united
states and that it should be closed down
that we should revert to openness and
telling telling it like it is and
telling the truth to people
i think secrecy doesn't work i think it
masks and provides a cover for people to
do things which would definitely be
unacceptable to the society at large
there's nothing they do that is
forthright
positive that you can stand up in church
or wherever you go and say i'm you know
this is what i did last week and i'm
proud of it overseas it's all you're a
secret operative that means your
existence there is a lie
you're pretending to be a diplomat or a
scholar or something which you're not
you're getting information
covertly and that means i mean we have
diplomats in these countries who talk to
people endlessly if the information is
overtly available
they will get it you're there to bribe
and to induce people to be spies to
commit treason
and you're also there to instigate
activities
meaning subversion now these are heavy
crimes in every country in the world
normally punishable by death this is
what the cia does i think he also made
the point before a well-taken point
again that if we just went into some of
these countries and and bought them with
money we'd be doing a lot more for our
american interest than if we tried to
insidiously you know overthrow their
governments uh give lsd to their leaders
uh hire prostitutes to be filmed in in
compromising positions with other
leaders if we just went in and just pump
some money into them and we could
probably buy more friends that way than
what the cia has been doing over the
last 20 years or so and and i even hedge
a little bit at the word buy friends
you know they have a
in the ci we had a saying that uh
you you can you can rent an african but
you can't buy
and uh because you know you make
payments to people and and uh as long as
it's in their interest to work with you
they will and then when you run out of
the situation changes they're going to
work continue to work in their interests
which may not be parallel to yours any
longer
but the point is that there are certain
techniques of interpersonal and
international relations which work on
the long term
and
lying cheating
deceit and skullduggery don't work in
the long term you put yourself down yes
if we would go in with this 13 billion
dollars alone and deal overtly with
people
i i'm sure and work for sincerely for
human rights
and for democratic action so that those
countries can try to have governments
like our own and systems like our own
surely we would be further ahead than we
are right now what about intelligence
gathering if they did that without the
dirty tricks
is that possible you think
well this question always comes up and
i've i've thought about it a great deal
for years now
and i conclude
my own personal conclusion
is quite firm
that the quality of our intelligence
would be much greater
if we did not have the ci's covert
collection
systems
if you've read anything about the ci and
kept up with it you've noticed that the
ci has a long history
of colossal intelligence failures i
don't mean covert operations that
exploded in our face and splattered us
with
with foul
propaganda and presence around the world
but i mean failure to to advise the
united states government on what is
happening in a given situation in the
world one of the more dramatic ones
recently was iran a year ago
where the the week that iran fell apart
that it broke down completely leading
directly to the shah's ouster
the ci head and its typewriters
a report a national intelligence
estimate
that there was no serious opposition to
the shah
in iran you have one side of the house
the operators of which i was one out
there recruiting spies and gathering
intelligence you have the other side of
the house are phds and people with
master's degrees who are professional
analysts and theoretically the system
should produce good intelligence the
argument they always throw out is that
the cia
you have to have the human agent to find
out what people intend to do
you can get their capabilities from
their missile
manuals and whatnot but what they intend
to do with those missiles you have to
have an agent penetration
the fallacy of this
is that
look at our own white house who would
you have to have as your spy in the
white house to know what the white house
is going to do i mean obviously the
white house doesn't know what it's going
to do in a given situation until usually
a day or two after it's done it
particularly and particularly this one
but the next one one was wasn't much
better and you would have had to had
henry kissinger in your pocket to have
an estimate of what was being done and
what he was going to do
spies are the most unreliable source of
information that can be had
a spy is by definition almost a person
of abnormal psychology
normal people don't betray their
countries
abnormal people do betray their
countries for various reasons a spy can
be
an adventurer who's out to have fun
making up information a fabricator for
various reasons a double agent working
for his own country and for you or
working for his own country against you
or working for the french against both
you and russia
and you add this all up inside the cia
we took our own spy information with
huge doses of salt i could go on and on
and on with with illustrations i think
the point that you made that's what was
well taken last time that you were on
the show was that uh an agency that
spends over 10 billion dollars a year
collects now less than oh less than okay
13 billion collects
a lot less than 10 percent of the actual
hardcore intelligence
i think what was the exact percentage
that you see yeah we were told inside
the ci on
things like mid-career course that the
clandestine services
collect
about four percent of the total gross
input and of that clearly a trivial
amount was important we all knew that
but we always lived for that one report
that you get that would be a big report
that would tell everything but see
the problem with secrecy in an
intelligence business is that
it it
look at the academic world and try to
picture it
if you were able to write your thesis to
convince one person
your your monitor your your professor
and no one else
you could go to the professor and find
out what his biases were and he didn't
have to convince anyone else but the
dean and you could go to him you could
go the two of you and have dinner with
the dean and find out how he felt about
that subject and you go back and write
it to make sure he's pleased and that
way you get your your degree
and you're happy and you succeed
and the quality of the information
plummets obviously in the ci you have to
convince your boss and his boss and it
goes up the chain of command to what
will sell to the very secret very tight
intelligence
establishment and you don't have to
convince anyone else and you can ask
them first what they want you to write
and this is how you get situations like
in in iran where you're reporting that
the shah is very stable because the
president like the shah the
before this president the others like
the shah there's a great
interrelationship of someone like the
shah with his billions of dollars
and our own moneyed establishment well
there's also a big relationship between
the uh secret uh service of the sabbath
and the cia they feed each other
information the ci put the shah in power
and helped him organize the savak and
there's no way that you could get a
report up through the chain of command
in the ci saying that the shah was
bankrupt it would not sell you'd get it
it would be torn up it would not get
published i believe you mentioned last
time you're on the show that the
cia has helped directly or indirectly
train most of the repressive
police forces in the in the world
including
uganda including brazil where they were
torturing priests and what have you in
the philippines in korea the kci kci
mobutu and zaire
the
the emperor in ethiopia his police force
these were all ci liaison
developed organizations we didn't train
them all we're not the only
people in the world who indulge in
unfortunate police activities the kgb i
don't think the cia
john doesn't the cia and its processes
of secrecy also undermine our own
democracy at home that if the policies
are being made and carried out
information gathered that's only
accessible to a few people you have
government by a corporate elite that's
not responsible to the democratic
process and again and again we paid for
this government by the people doesn't
work if you have a secret government
just forget it stop right there and it's
a fallacy that this is a more effective
way of government because we've seen
again and again that this creates
disasters whether we're talking about
iran and vietnam that the corporate
elite is not so all powerful or so
efficient and that maybe it's better to
trust the people and to debate some of
the policies and have ideas out in the
open
you know i watch on things like this tom
snyder show on nbc where the
the the turner is is on and given
national prime time to say that people
who attack the cia like stockwell and
others bill shep and others are
unamerican they're traitors was his word
and as i asked glenn while he said that
and
uh that's who is america admiral turner
the director of the cia now who is
american turner insists on secrecy and
he's lobbying for laws to put people
like me in jail for going to the
american people and telling what we've
done
in america's name with america's tax
dollars
and i ask you who is american who is the
traitor to the american system the john
stockwell and frank sneps and others who
are exercising the american principle of
participating of working together to
discuss what our country is doing and
try to influence it lord knows i might
be wrong in my position towards angola
or any position in the world but it's
the american process to stand up and
thrash it out and to debate it to get
both sides out in the open and to see
which side has the most merits and to
let the people
decide in angola we would not have had
that war i warrant if there had been
public debate
you had henry kissinger and bill colby
of the ci wanted this war
and they got it because they were able
to do it in secrecy they lied to the
senate in order to get it done
the american interests that were in
angola were significant you had gulf oil
and boeing doing business with the
angolan government they were not
permitted to vote to discuss to
participate in the decision to go to war
in angola they were distressed when it
happened when they found out they were
they were put out of business
temporarily by the secret war
the american churches had extensive
missionary organizations inside angola
and they were not permitted to to
participate in the decision to go into
angola
and and of course the american scholars
who were working in gold traveling the
exchanges they were not permitted to
participate you had two individuals
engineered this war who had never been
to angola and one of them had never set
foot in africa in his life
neither of them were africanists even
and they engineered a war and got it
done because of secrecy that's a very
good point that you've raised a fact
that not very many people know is that
the cia has been engaging or trying to
start these wars throughout the country
at least as far back as the days of
allen dulles
when alan dulles tried to get nixon
interested in starting a war in laos
back in 54 and 55 and when that fell
through he later repeatedly took marine
helicopters out of leias flew him into
saigon airport
and created a threat where there had
been none before and hence their
involvement in southeast asia was alan
dulles's attempt to start a war over
there which he later was successful in
doing although kennedy and johnson have
taken most of the blame for the
escalation of the war i'm glad you said
that because i say it every time i
lecture
this this we're not playing with little
secret operations that affect no one
our our economic problems now are
greatly tied to this 165 billion
disaster in vietnam that was a ci
operation for at least seven years
before we began an overt military
campaign
the the cia was deeply involved in a
secret war in southeast asia and trying
to get the united states government
involved the first whistleblower
was a gentleman named paul sakwa who was
not because of the mood of the nation
and the press and whatnot was not given
an audience he did not succeed in
speaking out he didn't have quite the
whatever it takes to write a book and
get it published but he resigned his job
in the early sixties in protest over the
cia's efforts to to lobby to [ __ ]
the american public about what was
happening in vietnam
and he quit because the station in
saigon was putting out false information
consciously discussing their ploys to
lobby to get the americans to wake up to
the threat and do quote the right thing
the ci remind remember has published by
then it had published a couple of
thousand english language books that
means for american consumption
that were secretly published by the ci
paying someone to write a book
and and many of those books at that time
were about vietnam john how have you
succeeded in getting your message across
to the american people the mass media
been
open
and willing to discuss your more radical
ideas about
abolishing the cia are they willing to
debate this last time i talked to you on
the phone you were talking about a
letter that you'd written to the new
york times or a column for the op-ed
page about the abolition of the c.i.a
did they ever publish that
no
the initial reaction of the press and
the mass media to me was was quite good
i would say there was 98 or 99 favorable
the one exception was the washington
post which is conspicuously washington
establishment newspaper and very close
to the cia
but
since the the initial impact of
publicity of who is john stockwell and
what does he have to say
simultaneously as the months have
tracked there's been a change in the
stance of our of our government our
establishment including our press
establishment
uh responding to president carter's line
and vice president mondale's line and
admiral turner's lobbying to get off the
ci's back and permit it to get back to
work
and this is very conspicuous if you read
the editorial uh sections of the
washington post and the new york times
and time magazine and newsweek it i mean
it's not a covert subtle thing they're
coming out and saying it let's get off
get off the cia's back and let them get
back to work well of course work you
know for the cia is is
highness crimes against humanity that's
their function that's how this shows
something very disturbing and that is
how the mass media and the political
establishment go along with these cia
games that they're dupes or are they
willing
accomplices how do you read the role of
the media you know i was complaining
about
exactly this just a couple of days ago
to a friend of mine on the new york
times and another friend on the
washington post on the long distance
telephone
pointing out that our press has accepted
a stance
which makes it sort of the the willing
uh
participant
in such government
misdeeds employees and and
and blunders
what the press does essentially is they
report they try to report facts there
are obvious biases and whatnot but
essentially they report facts
if president carter makes a speech
the word it's the fact that he made a
speech
and it's a fact that he said this that
or the other the fact that everything he
said is a lie the press doesn't take it
as their responsibility to point that
out
so what they do is when a crisis like
this develops they quote they have you
know there's the the fact that the
president said such and so and somebody
else and somebody else and senator
church
and and
senator jackson and who was a senator
from florida
and their lies and misstates statements
and exaggerations
are become the issue even though they're
false and even though everyone involved
in the press knows that they're false
no one in the press points this out to
the readers
even the
editors who write their columns rarely
tackle the president or the secretary of
state
or even an admiral turner they will take
him on some time but they how often do
you read
an article did you after the
the president's speech the other night
about this crisis was there any
editorial in a major newspaper that said
that he he lied on point after point
after point well you know i think john
pointed out before when he was on the
show that the cia
is now i guess and admitted that they
have bought journalists in the past but
you also pointed out that a lot of
events were staged for the benefit of
the press and stories are of course
spoon fed to the press
by the cia and most of these go
unchallenged well there's a social
relationship
and class relationship with the upper
people who control the newspapers that
are in the newspapers
the old boy network this has been
pointed out by you know
many months back when they were talking
about cia and press relationships
they press people of the top members of
the press meet in the bilderberg group
along with members of the cia they're in
the same
social clubs
they know each other on a personal basis
so naturally there's going to be a
relationship and what what evolves is
the end result of all this is that the
ci's existence in the 50s and the 60s
when it galloped so
it got so far out of line
drug sex experiments on unwitting
american guinea pigs
uh uh assassination attempts of world
leaders very successful some successful
and and many many uh crimes that you can
only describe as depraved
and vietnam war in the angular war and
coups and these things
were permissible this this evolution of
this organization was possible only with
the indulgence of the press if the press
had been alert had been smoking this
organization out had been reporting that
the ci is doing this that
and the other it could never have gotten
by with it this is my big disappointment
now is to see the nation the
establishment turning and the press
establishment this is what i said over
the phone just
yesterday i think the last conversation
was in this series of conversations was
just that that we're heading right back
where we were with the indulgence of the
press the press is cooperating with the
government to put the ci back in action
just where it was
mind you
we've gone through all of these
exposures of 1975 and 76 and and the
ci's charter has actually been expanded
in the last three years since then well
john you were talking about the press
and the fact that they have not
performed this watchdog
function
even when they have the opportunity such
as your letter to the new york times
tell us about that
well there have been there have been a
couple i don't i don't have the time to
spend a lot of time writing all the
letters that occur to me obviously i
think we all have that syndrome of
reading something and say boy i'd like
to answer that myself
and occasionally i i read something and
i really do feel like i have something
valid to say
but
last year i got a call from an editor of
the new york times who said that
they had run an article from congressman
stratton a letter calling for a stronger
expanded cia and deploring the fact that
the nation was weak because the ci was
in trouble it was broken down they had
run a letter from admiral turner saying
don't worry about it
we need help we need your support but
but we're still out there pitching so
don't don't worry about it too much
but give us your help and this guy who's
i believe mind and heart are pretty
honest and pretty much in the right
place called me and he said we gotta
have somebody come in and say wait a
minute you know the other side of that
is is calling for a closure of the cia
and so why don't you write that one
stockpool and i spent three weeks i
didn't do anything else i wrote this
thing and i rewrote it i talked to him
on the phone i rewrote it i rewrote it i
rewrote it i rewrote it and they never
ran it did i ever tell you why
i talked to him endlessly but
essentially it boiled down at the end
he he quit returning my phone calls
because he was getting embarrassed
because essentially the the one editor
comes up with an article he likes and he
shops it around the other editors and if
they all sort of agree it gets momentum
going until the boss says okay let's run
with it and he couldn't get the momentum
the the they just weren't going to run
an article that was anti-ci and they did
not
and my own experience by the way
in dealing with the new york times that
time and three other occasions
and dealing with washington post or i've
also published
is that what the new york times is
is at least 10 times as enlightened as
the washington post
well this most recent letter which you
wrote to the new york times also reveals
the same type of thinking you wrote to
them about the cuban situation
did you not yes i i wrote to him about
the cuban situation and uh i must admit
this time i was wiser and more
experienced and also
the editor that i was talking to was
quite candid with me and quite
straightforward
and
he told me the reasons quite promptly
why they couldn't run it it was very
frustrating to me because i thought it
should be run
and he would say he agreed and then he
would say but it's not going to run
that's obviously it just you know and
that that small group of people that
article was not going to get priority
over the others
but the same principle is that no one
has pointed out on in an international
organ a western international organ that
this thing started with a ci operation
which got out of hand it was a little
bit more successful than the ci ever
dreamed and politics
john you've been traveling a lot
in trying to help get established to
make arrangements for a documentary
which will be produced by bbc and be
shown hopefully on pbs and then
hopefully by the
affiliates there's a lot of hope along
the line there
you've made three trips to cuba what are
your impressions of cuba and the cuban
people and the system they have down
there
you know
i when i went to cuba the first time i
felt a little bit
like one of these longhorn football
players might feel if during ou week he
found himself up in oklahoma
and he's walking around with people and
he finds they're really nice people you
know the hysteria that you get and the
bad guys down there in cuba i'd been so
brainwashed even trying to be
intelligent
and see through our ci propaganda i had
been so brainwashed against communism
that i i just
i couldn't believe what i actually saw
in cuba now mind you the the nature and
mentality of the cuban people is i'm
sure vastly different from the soviets
in the soviet union i've not been to
moscow and from everything i read about
it and i'm not sure how much of it cia
written books and how much of its
legitimate books i'm not eager to go
except maybe as a tourist it strikes me
as a fairly bleak
climate and a political atmosphere that
i wouldn't want to live in
but
that may not be the fault of communism i
got down in cuba and i found people
were incredibly open you know you have
the stereotype of the oppressive
communist state where people are afraid
to talk and are afraid to talk to a
foreigner and everything
and they were urging me to go out on the
streets and talk to anyone i wanted to
and we would have these conversations
they wanted to tell me about their
system they're proud of it a lot of fun
they wanted to tell me about the
operations they had run they wanted to
brag about how they had clobbered us in
angola and whatnot and you know you're
sitting there at uh
at a dinner you know hosted by the film
uh
national film company and present at
that particular dinner of
eight people or something was a member
of the central committee and you know
it's kind of a little bit heavy and and
uh some
party commissar and then a couple of
people make films and then
one interpreter and uh because i don't
speak spanish very well and
this one guy from the film institute
everybody else orders uh mojitos this
national drink down there except him he
he orders a brandy alexander
and
then he proceeds for 45 minutes to tell
us all how he's really an anarchist he's
realist communism and everything yeah
okay it's better than capitalism for
cuba but basically i don't believe in
any government much less communism or
capitalism and he goes on and on with
this and the central committee member is
arguing with him and they're pouring
their drinks and having and you know
this isn't the way you visualize a
communist country working
they have they have
cuba
was you know this is abundantly
documented it was the brothel the
whorehouse of of the west of the united
states it was where you went to play
playground for the month playground for
the mafia playground for the rich new
york bankers for the people in america
who had money they went to cuba to play
it wasn't a very good deal for the cuban
people 80 percent of the country was
owned by outside money from from the
sugar lands to the banks to what
factories there were it was owned by
outside
castro
got power organized it along communist
lines
and now the country belongs to the
people
and there is no way that ci propaganda
can can make a case that the people in
cuba
regret that
they have so much more of a stake in
what's going on in their country and
they're so proud of it now they're
exceptions this is what they kept
telling me they said get out and talk to
people and you're going to find people
are unhappy and they're going to tell
you problems we haven't solved all our
problems lord knows every time we solve
a problem we create two more
but we're trying and we think the people
are involved and that's what it appeared
to me they're certainly more involved
than they were 20 years ago when they
were owned
by by the mafia john did you see
evidence of increased democratization
going on in cuba they had some local
elections i think last year
for the first time and fidel seemed to
say that well before the people weren't
ready for elections but now they've had
experience political experience
education and they're ready and we're
going to have more and more democracy
did you get a sense that democracy was
on the rise
there do you have any well i very much
did
i i went i was i visited schools and i
visited apartment complexes and i talked
to people about how
is you know how is it working how do you
elect your representative and who does
you know who who gets to vote and we
would go into schools now obviously
uh my two trips there where i'm very
busy working on a film project which
does not have uh it has
20 or 30 to do with cuba
doesn't make me an authority on cuba i'm
not a cuban scholar i haven't been deep
into the place i've seen sort of you
know whirlwind tours through here and
there
when they would take me on these tours
they would sort of point to a side of
town where which was built up in the
last 20 years and then they'd make me
say where to turn and make me say where
to stop and make me say what building to
go into and what floor to stop on and
which door to knock on to talk to people
so they they really were trying to make
an effort to let me find people to talk
to and i came away with the
very definitely the strong impression
that the people are involved but they're
also involved in electing their own
officials now again i hedge a little bit
because i'm not a cuban scholar or an
authority on cuba i understand your book
is out on paperback now
yes how's the distribution of that going
you know it's gone extremely well but we
did not get a mass-market sale norton
brought it out in paperback and we got
the best i could tell bookstores around
the nation began running it in april and
they still are
and it is selling it's selling quite
well
it's an interesting thing you learn when
you write a book and of course you know
you want to get a paperback sale and you
want to get a movie
any author wants these things to happen
uh paperback sales are
the paperback business is perhaps one of
the squirliest of the
the nation's businesses the the rule the
reasons that they will give you for
choosing one book and not another one
are incomprehensible
things like for example my book
frank snep's book
my book about the ci sneps book about
the evacuation of the u.s from from
vietnam
did not get a mass-market sale but phil
caputo's book
rumors of war
about a marine lieutenant's experience
in vietnam 10 years ago and how he was
disgusted with the war and what not was
was a million dollar paperback hyped and
sold all over the nation but they didn't
pick up snaps book which is what
happened recently you know what it's all
about
uh cy hersh you know who broke me lie
he was in vietnam he got onto the story
he refused to drop it he resisted
intimidation and he he cracked me lie
and a series of articles and he pounded
away until he got prosecution on it he
kept after it until he did milai and he
wrote a book and he's a talented writer
and he wrote a book
about how i cracked me like the inside
story of what all happened trying to get
this story out and it didn't get a mass
market sale if you can believe that but
it didn't
and so
what they'll tell you in new york is
that they look for books that have a
certain
little touch or flair that they can do
one book for a million dollars instead
of 10 for 100 000 dollars and so a lot
of very good books don't
get paperback sales
mention the movie that
might be made of your book what's
happening with that project well i'm i'm
learning as i go along about books and
about movies i've got
three parties
two in new york and one in california
and one of the ones in new york has
california connections
that are heavyweights that are people
that are capable of doing big movies of
books like this who are talking to me
very seriously i've had four
written offers
proposals and i rejected them because
there was a flaw in each one that made
them unacceptable
but
pull for me a little bit of luck
and
and we might get a
really exciting movie about this this
book in search of enemies in closing i
wonder if you could tell your
thoughts on how you feel
about your having taken a moral stand
against the cia criticized its crimes
its dirty tricks whereas william colby
the former director who was in charge of
the phoenix program that was literally a
program of genocide has continued to
defend the cia and travels around the
country in defense of it and has gotten
a lot of media play and is taken as one
of the pillars of the establishment
whereas you're looked up on a bit as an
outsider how do you feel about this plus
the fact that colby is now retired and
rather opulent splendor in his little
sailboat and here you're struggling to
make ends meet
well
i don't have any
great sense of bitterness
i think it's an unfortunate statement
about our society and the way things are
that someone can't like colby can have
blood up to his armpits
the deaths and programs that he
personally ordered and managed
total at least 40 000 people dead and
that's just two programs there were a
lot of others
and he retires with great dignity as you
say an honor
but i don't feel
the slightest bit
of
lack of dignity or
dishonor in my own position absolutely
not i have not been
i have not had a single experience in
which people made me feel
less worthwhile or less worthwhile than
colby he did
run out his full career and get his
pension
he did have his
legal degree and because of connections
that he had through the cia he's
established a practice and
comfortable business was thrown his way
i would say the only thing
that aside from the moral issue of a
person who has committed gross crimes
against humanity
not nearly the scale and scope of
holocaust but the same principle
is is admired and leads a dignified life
aside from that
just practically the way he lives the
only thing
that i regret is the trend in the nation
to give people like bi-universities
primarily to give people like colby
and
former president ford
and admiral turner and kissinger
abundant
fully funded opportunities to lecture
and they stand up and lie
and tell it like it was not
and people like myself who are willing
to to go before the same groups of
people and tell it like it is and tell
the truth and tell what happened
and
i lectured at uc san diego uh six weeks
after president ford had been there
ex-president it
and
he had rece he had lectured for one hour
much of what he'd said was patent lies
not true statements
he answered three questions and left in
a limousine and got ten thousand dollars
i stayed for about five hours talking to
those uh people
and uh
did my level best to tell the truth and
provide accurate insights
and i got four hundred dollars
and this and this is unfortunate it's uh
it's a further statement of the trend of
the times
the establishment is back in people like
colby
are getting a wider audience turner is
invited to lecture and permitted to
stand up and deliver his lies and he's
funded for it yes i regret that
i have i have to pay my rent and i'm
succeeding in paying my rent
but
i would be a little bit happier with the
situation if i had
more opportunities to lecture even than
i do
and
more economic freedom to to get about
more and lecture more to people that are
interested but that's a small detail and
it certainly was not a surprise
when i
let's face it when you're sitting inside
the ci at the level of a colonel a
younger man
you're not a director you haven't had
national
international prominence
and you quit the cia and you
you attack them you write a book
exposing them
you're
you don't expect to have the cia and the
establishment uh pat you on the back and
buy your limousine and and set you up
for life you know that you're going to
be
a little bit of an outsider at best in
fact you worry about things much more
profound than that are you going to
survive
are you going to be hurt or your
children going to be hurt these are the
things that you think about and decide
probably not you will survive and they
won't bother your family but certainly
you're not going to be offered a hundred
thousand dollar a year job with exxon or
gulf oil or some such
well john we really thank you for
dropping by again these are really
exciting programs and from the response
the people and the various audiences
we've had
also consider it that way so
keep it up i'm really proud to have been
part of this show it's a very worthwhile
show well come back again all right
thanks john goodnight
you